hello everyone and welcome to the start
of the croatian grand chess tour that is
being played in zagreb
it's yani palmishi versus shakhtar
mahmoud yarov and this is round two
of the event so in the first round both
of them started with a win uh nepo
defeated uh
anton corbeau whereas mamidarov defeated
maxime bashar lagrave and now they face
each other
uh it's a really good game and i thought
it'd be uh nice to start it off
with this one so we're gonna talk about
the the
uh tour and the the players the players
a little bit more after we get into it
but basically it's the third stage of
the 2021 grand chester it's a series of
five events
with a total price fund of one million
two hundred and seventy five
thousand dollars where nipple here is
the top seed uh
and uh well there are a lot of very
strong players also there are guests uh
even character
the the top creation grand master will
be playing in the rapid section
and then after the three days of rapid
we're gonna have two days of blitz and
then uh gary caspar
will take shot its place as the wild
card in the in the blitz event so it's
going to be
a really awesome event uh we're going to
have a lot of fun uh so let's uh check
it out so nipple with
the white pieces opens with c4
and here we're not gonna dwell too long
on the opening we rarely
do but here we're really not going to be
because it's a really really explored
territory and it's a first
23 four five moves are basically known
theory
so here knight to f6 we have g3
g6 bishop to g2 and bishop to g7 so
going for the english
opening we have knight to c3 and now
castles by mommy they are we have d4 and
the d6 we have e4 now
uh grabbing the center here controlling
a lot of squares in the center
and the e5 now by mamedyarov we have
knight g to e2
uh both players just uh continuing
development putting pieces on optimal
squares
uh and here usually black just continues
with developing his other knight but uh
here mamidaro wanted to
maybe trick nepal a little bit and he
uh made a trade in the center so he
captures on d4 we have knight captures
and only now rook to e8
attacking the e4 pawn twice but it's
already defended twice so
uh we can simply castle the safety so
castles we have knight b to d7
and now h3 we have a6 both players just
playing useful moves we rook to e1 and
now
rook to b8 preparing to strike with b5
so bishop to e3 just continuing
development and
now knight to e5 with an attack on the
c4 pawn
so nipple defensive we have b3 and now
c5
challenging this knight basically
getting it away from the defense of the
b5 square
so knight the d back to e2 and only now
b5
uh we have f4 uh nipple uh counters with
an attack on the
well on the king side dislodges the
knight from the center we have knight e
to d7
and now this pawn is free for grabs so
nipple of course captures it and this is
still all
very known theory even this uh pawn grab
because
black will get some counter play so here
b4
challenging this knight but now not
retreating with the knight but rather e5
attacking black's knight here but now b
captures in c3
but now you can't really play e captures
on f6 because
also your bishop here would be hanging
although you could play it but it really
gives a
black a better position for example rook
captures you can even grab the bishop on
g7
but now we chase the queen away from
this active square and once the queen
retreats we're gonna play rook to e6
and black has a very scary position here
if anyone's better here is definitely
black there's a pass pawn on c3 you have
double the rooks and the e file the
queen
can join them so it's uh well it's just
a better position for black
so instead we have knight captures in c3
now saying okay you can be up a piece
but
as the you know as you've seen the
thumbnail
it's a really really uh weird position
where material isn't everything and
uh well you have to develop your pieces
otherwise you're just going to be
really really behind in development and
you're not going to be able to find any
useful moves
so here we have knight to h5 and now g4
sort of trapping the knight but not
really uh because you have bishop to f8
you attack the queen
and now you can retreat to g7 with your
knight we have queen back to b2 now
comes knight to g7
and now knight the d5 and here
uh what do you what do you play here
well you could continue with some like
bishop to b7 you
uh really want to start developing your
pieces almost all of them are in the
back rank these knights are
are on the seventh rank uh but we have
f6
which is still a known move uh and now
comes
rook 8 to d1 so not worried about
anything in the center
uh we have f captures on e5 by
mamedyarov and now
uh feel free to pause the video and try
to find what
nipple had in mind here while i give you
a couple of seconds even though
this has all been played before
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not
uh trying to grab the pawn on e5 or
playing something weird although it's a
really really hard to find any move
other than the one that was played in
the game so congratulations to everyone
who found something other than that
well if you found rook to f1 that's
reasonable that's that's fine
uh but f5 is the move you had to find
and congratulations to everyone who
played this because now
uh white is just much better and the
thing is uh
it doesn't matter if you capture here
white will just capture back with this
pawn there's still going to be this
spawn
and your actual thread is f6 f7 that's
uh and the
black does doesn't really have a move
that he can play to try and get out of
this so here we have bishop to b7
and it is only now as of move 23 that we
have a completely new game
so there is one game where instead of
this bishop to be seven bishop the e7
was played but this
is now a new move so let's see how
nipple deals with this and
it's um uh pretty pretty fair to say
that mamadou probably did not know what
he was doing up until this point because
here white is already much better
but of course nepal will try to take
advantage of that so bishop to g5 first
improving the bishop attacking the queen
we have queen to c8 and now rook to f1
and rook to f1 is deadly here
uh you could also capture here but rook
to f1 simply with the threat of f6
and f7 it's uh too too much for
for black to handle uh the problem is
you don't have a useful move if you
play some like captures then we capture
with check and we win back our piece so
that's out of the question
and if you try to just waste a move
sometimes you can do that sometimes you
can just
wait and nothing bad will happen but
here again just f6 f7 and
there's no playing this so uh instead
after rook f2 f1 uh first we capture g
captures on f5 we have g captures on f5
the same threat remains and
now king to h8 so now uh
this f7 uh push will no longer come with
check but nepo still continues pushing
with
f6 uh f6 knights to e6 and now
f7 although worth mentioning is bishop
to e4
since it's really deadly the threat is
bishop captures on h7 and then you just
wiggle
in the queen queen c2 check queen g6 and
then you check mate the
uh the black king but then black will
have to give up the
bishop here and then after you capture
back they will or better yet with the
queen
it's just a really really bad position
for black you've given up your only
active piece for the moment
uh but okay uh it's a rapid game nipple
played f7 attacking the rook and now uh
we have uh rook to d8 so now i'm putting
the rook on the same file as the queen
but now you have to find a good move and
here a tricky a very tricky move is
knight to e7 but nippo decides to do it
the other way around
he fi he basically does the same thing
only way cooler
he plays knight to b6 now gives up a
full piece here
but he's going to get a lot in return so
here knight captures some b6 but now
we don't capture anything back like uh
queen captures on the 8 or bishop
captures first we deliver bishop to f6
check and now the black king doesn't
have any squares you have to defend this
bishop to g7
and only now that the bishop has moved
we play queen captures on the eighth we
have queen captures
and now bishop captures on d8
and now uh the problem for black is you
can't really capture this piece because
if you go after it
rook captures rook captures and knight
captures uh well then you
uh remove the defender of the f8 square
so if knight captures we just bring
another queen into the game with
check bishop captures rook capture so
now we're gonna pick up this
knight here and uh well it's just the
bishop and rook against the knight and
the bishop of course completely winning
for white
so instead uh after bishop captures on
the eighth uh mamadiara first exchanges
the
light square bishop we have king
captures and now knight to f8
but it's not um well it's not going to
do him all that much
we have bishop to e7 now attacking the
c5 pawn
and knight beat to d7 defending it but
now the problem is that the knights are
guarding each other and you never want
to have this
it's just uh you will not be able to
move either of the knights and it's just
uh you know
it's better to have one good night than
two useless nights
so here we have rook to d6 now putting
pressure on the a6 pawn and now
e4 nepo get uh mamidarov gives up the a6
pawn
in order to play bishop to d4 and then
cement this pawn on e3 so it could be a
very dangerous pass pawn later on in the
game
but we have rooked to e1 nepal says i
don't need the ace exponent i can grab
it whenever i want let's eliminate
this pawn first and there isn't anything
mommy daryl can do about that
he plays bishop to d4 we have rook
capture sunny for and now king to g7
he's going after the f7 pawn
we have rook characters on a6 and now
king captures on f7 we have bishop to d6
now
attacking the rook here uh and rook to
c8 you have to keep the rook on the back
rank uh
otherwise white will get his rook up to
the back rank and it's
going to be really bad or to the seventh
rank it's still i mean the two knights
still guarding each other it's it's just
terrible so rook to c8
and now comes rook the e7 with check
king to g8 and now rook to a7 and now if
white can
give up the rook for the two knights
then it's just completely winning
because now
uh white is up two pawns so knight to f6
and now rook the g7 with check king
king h8 and now rook g back to b7
we have knight to e4 but it doesn't
matter we have rook to b8
just trading off of black's last rook uh
we have knight
captures on d6 rook captures on c8
knight
captures and now of course rook to a8
and now you're going to win
back material so knights to d6 we have
rook captures on f8 king to g7 and now
rogue back to a8 and here it's a rook
against the bishop and knight which is
usually good for the bishop and knight
but you're still down two pawns
so here bishop to c3 trying to create
some sort of a barrier on the a5 square
but it doesn't work nipple just place a4
we have knight to b7 trying to guard the
square but now the knight and the king
are on the same file
so uh rook to a7 and it was in this
position and move 50 that uh shakhtar
and mamjar resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
the knight is hanging and
well it cannot move otherwise the king
would be in check and that's it you lose
the knight and then of course it's a
it's a very straightforward win
uh so really an exciting start uh to
today
although this is a game from round two
and uh there were a couple of more
interesting games so i will try to show
them uh but of course do you use hashtag
suggestions suggest your
your favorite game and i will try to
check it out and
if it's a nice one if i consider it to
be uh worth
showing then we're gonna uh we're gonna
enjoy it
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it a nice game to start off this
tournament with
i would like to thank rodrigo alves
karen scarfone uh david kimura
christopher denninger and
2020 rendezvous for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon by
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day